the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season 8 video unfortunately
HBO has yet to release their first
official trailer for Game of Thrones but
they did however release another teaser
for their upcoming shows in 2019
hopefully none of you did blink or else
you might have missed it but let's talk
about it anyway there appears to be more
footage from what is most likely the
opening scene of the season as we all
know Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen are
on their way to Winterfell to get ready
for the upcoming battle against the
night King this will be the very first
time we have seen Daenerys Targaryen
step foot inside of the Starks own now
HBO has already released a few teasers
showing Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen
arrival the first one showed Jon and
Sansa embracing each other after Jon had
been gone for quite some time in that
clip we could see that Sansa was looking
at someone as her and Jon hugged each
other most of us had already assumed
that she was looking at Daenerys
Targaryen that was later confirmed when
HBO released another teaser showing
Daenerys and saw ins a meeting for the
first time what they gave us today is
just another extension of that scene as
we all know not only is Jon and Daenerys
arriving in Winterfell but so is
Daenerys entire force in the new scene
we can see the unsullied and the Dragons
flying overhead as they reach the Starks
castle now what we see next is actually
kind of hilarious obviously the main
attraction is Arya Stark but take a look
at what is happening right behind her
the arrival of the Dragons is literally
scaring the out of everyone else
you have to keep in mind just like what
the way Walkers most of the people of
Westeros have assumed that all of the
dragons were dead now I'm sure that they
have heard more than enough stories
about Daenerys Targaryen and her dragons
but actually seeing them in real life
would have to be absolutely terrifying
well that is except for Ari
ARC she doesn't appear to be worried at
all actually she even has a bit of a
smile come across her face now I did
have a pretty good feeling that she
would in one of my recent videos I even
said that I believe Aria will like
Daenerys more than Sansa does some of
you may or may not remember but Aria
told us what she thought about some of
the legendary members of House Targaryen
student of history
Rhaenys rode meraxes señor Vega I'm sure
I knew that my name as a boy I'm saying
a Targaryen was a great warrior had a
Valyrian steel sword she called dark
sister she's a heroine of yours I take
it so as you can see Arya will most
likely have a great deal of respect for
Daenerys Targaryen especially when she
sees her riding the dragons into battle
hopefully this is a sign that Arya and
Daenerys will become friends rather
quickly now of course there is another
reason why Arya might be smiling in that
scene
now that the unsullied and the dragons
are showing up at wonderful this can
only mean one thing
Jon Snow is arriving as well not only
could already be looking at the dragons
in the scene but she might also see Jon
Snow someone we all know she loves very
much I'm going to miss you
careful
these two characters have been seen each
other since the second episode of the
first season in fact John is one of the
main reasons why oriya even decided to
come home in the first place she was on
her way to go kill Cersei Lannister but
that was until hop I told her John and
Sansa had retaken Winterfell by winning
the Battle of the bastards I felt like I
should mention that because Arya could
be looking at Jon in that scene too but
if you do look into her eyes it does
look like she is looking up into the sky
at the dragons this opening episode of
the final season should have one hell of
an opening scene we will be seeing Jon
Snow Daenerys Targaryen Tyrion Lannister
Davos Seaworth Sandor Clegane Jorah
Mormont ginjury Brienne and many many
others arriving at Winterfell at the
same time with a massive army marching
along with them not only does Daenerys
have all of the unsullied soldiers but
she does still have a very big army of
Dothraki soldiers as well the knight
King and the army of the Dead are about
to have their hands full when they do
eventually show up the battle when the
north will truly be epic and I know it's
something that I cannot wait to see I
really wish they would release an
official trailer that way we could just
get a glimpse of some of those scenes
now I know that a lot of you think they
are gonna release a trailer tonight but
I'm not so sure that they will not after
they uploaded this already today
unfortunately we may never get a trailer
because HBO might want to keep the final
season as hush-hush as possible they
have already been very careful when it
comes to releasing footage from the
final season so far all we keep getting
is footage from the opening scene but
like I said before when and if they do
release a trailer I will break down
every single frame as promised until
then let me know what you think about
the short clip from today anyways I will
keep the videos short since there was
only about 5 seconds of footage to
analyze I want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching the video I
appreciate that as always and I also
want to thank everyone on patreon for
supporting the channel I hope you all
have a great day I'll see you soon
by
[Music]
you